[Music]  yep that's me I'm Ferdinand is like very  big more beetle of very strong ready to  put those wings to work watch  oh no you shot Maria into the Sun sorry  family of pepper was the good boy but  the world sees Ferdinand is one thing a  fighter I am here design a couple my  hunts are my instruments ice are my arms  next tests and buttocks no I'll pass  thanks you guys go ahead I know exactly  how certain she is let's go out there  and give it a 110% actually I'm gonna  pass in the violence  you're finally ready to fight come on I  am NOT a fighting boy movie sends a  message that resonates very strongly  with me don't judge a bull by his cover  there are places out there where you  don't get pushed around for being  yourself heads for one and hog for  everybody  [Music]  from the creators of Isis and Rio  I'm getting out of this place can you  just try to be a little more quiet the  door to freedom just do exactly what we  do exactly as we do  you